This is Marla, a 59 year-old woman
who has become obese as she aged.
She has also smoked cigarettes for
many years.
As a result, she's developed
several chronic diseases.
Through Marla and her story we'll
learn about chronic disease and
the problem it creates for
the US healthcare system.
We'll also gain the background to
appreciate the key role health
informatics can play in
helping solve those problems.
First, Marla is not unusual.
The Federal government's Medicare
program provides healthcare for
some 40 million people
over the age of 65, and
pays for
nearly half of all US hospital care.
It is projected to be a major
contributor to future increases in
healthcare spending.
83% of Medicare beneficiaries have
at least one chronic disease, but
the 23% that have five or more, account
for two thirds of Medicare's costs.
Here is a list of relatively
common chronic diseases, so
now you know what some of them are.
I could have added cancer,
since many people were surviving it and
being treated for years, but
we'll use this list for now.
If you, anyone in your family,
or anyone you know closely,
have had hypertension, diabetes,
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease,
heart disease or
chronic kidney disease, check that now